dans l'actualité ce soir aimé césaire
est mort à 94 ans poète et homme
politique autorité morale il avait été
l'un des pères de l'idée de négritude la
martinique prépare le deuil
l'état va organiser dimanche des
obsèques nationales en présence du
président de la république nicolas
sarkozy qui a lancé aujourd'hui son
projet de réforme de l'hôpital les
petits établissements ne devraient pas
fermé mais les services seront regroupés
et les directeurs ont plus de pouvoir
la polémique est toujours vive sur les
allocations familiales le gouvernement
annonce une compensation de 50 euros par
mois pour soixante mille familles
modestes qui font garder leurs enfants
à gauche ségolène royal dénonce un
scandale à l'étranger pas de cadeaux
entre hillary clinton et barack obama
lors d'un débat la nuit dernière la
candidate accuse son adversaire d'être
élitiste et pas assez patriotes le
prestige de la sorbonne s'exporte dans
le désert des émirats la filiale de
l'université parisienne qui a ouvert à
abou dhabi accueille 200 élèves de 30
nationalités c'est le dossier de cette
édition
enfin après le tourisme industriel et le
tourisme et écologique voici le tourisme
scientifique des chercheurs du cnrs
guide les vacanciers exemple ce soir
l'écosystème si particulier du mont
saint michel
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous il était
écrivain il était un homme politique il
était surtout l'une des grandes voix de
la france dans le monde
aimé césaire 94 ans est donc mort chez
lui en martinique où il était
hospitalisé depuis plusieurs jours sur
place anne ponsinet dominique bonnel on
ne peut pas dire que ce soit une
surprise au parti progressiste
martiniquais fondée par césaire on
redoutait cette nouvelle depuis
plusieurs jours
mais l'émotion est là les valeurs on
relit des citations du poète pour
préparer les cérémonies
s'il est fondé sur le respect de notre
identité pour ses vieux compagnons le
départ d'aimé césaire laisse un très
grand vide
c'était une énorme puissance 8 ans et
leur enclos perdu même tonalité dans le
quartier trénelle ce quartier populaire
pour lequel aimé césaire avait beaucoup
plus vrai le train il a fait beaucoup
d'enfants y avait pas de cette wilaya
n'est pas beaucoup mais il a fait
beaucoup de choses à part dieu comme ça
et on ne trouve pas d'autres c'est
surtout du maire qu'il nous parle de
l'homme qui siégea ici 56 ans durant
dans le bâtiment de l'ancienne mairie il
y conserver encore un bureau au premier
étage
tous les jours les matins ils recevaient
encore des personnalités des inconnus
laurence faisait partie des habitués et
faisait partie de ma vie je parlais ici
j'ai même pas besoin des fois mais
parler je voulais juste le voir et je me
souviens et après toutes ces années de
vie publique
il est temps pour la martinique de
regarder aimé césaire partir pour son
dernier voyage
aimé césaire est est considéré par
beaucoup comme un sage et un éveilleur
de conscience mais sans jamais vouloir
opposer les uns aux autres portraits
signés nicolas lemarignier hommes
politiques hommes de l'être aimé césaire
et et les deux à la fois c'est par la
culture que l'homme prend conscience de
lui-même prend conscience de son
identité
né en 1913 ce fils d'un inspecteur des
impôts martiniquais fait ses études au
lycée louis le grand à paris
où il se lie d'amitié avec léopold sédar
senghor en 32e il crée la revue
l'étudiant noir première prise de
conscience en 39 dans le cahier d'un
retour au pays natal apparaît le concept
de négritude nous sommes d'origine
africaine je n'ai jamais accepté le
piétinement de l'afrique
aimé césaire est élu maire de fort de
france ont 45 face à la surpopulation et
la crise économique
le jeune politicien veut moderniser la
martinique le suis pas du tout
pessimiste mais je dis simplement que
nous sommes à un tournant et il faut
savoir prendre ce tournant en 56 l'homme
de gauche fonde son propre parti
anticolonialiste aimé césaire est aussi
partisan de l'attachement de la
martinique à la france en marge de la
politique
le poète poursuit son oeuvre il exprime
ses convictions aussi au théâtre en 2001
après 56 ans demande à aimé césaire rend
son écharpe de maire mais s'intéresse
toujours à la politique en 2005
lorsqu'un article de loi controversé
reconnaît le rôle positif de la
colonisation
il refuse de rencontrer nicolas sarkozy
alors ministre de l'intérieur
ce qu'il fera finalement un an plus tard
en 2007 il soutient ségolène royal
aujourd'hui aimé césaire laisse un
héritage culturel immense son oeuvre
fait partie des classiques de la poésie
francophone
bonsoir anne consignes et vous êtes en
direct de fort de france en martinique
aimé césaire aura donc droit à des
obsèques nationales dimanche
oui la france se prépare à organiser des
obsèques nationales pour aimé césaire
avec l'avenue unique de nicolas sarkozy
le président de la république
dimanche il sera donc là le jour où aimé
césaire sera porté en terre dans un
cimetière de fort de france
on parle aussi de la venue d'un certain
nombre de personnes à l'époux de
personnalités politiques
mais là nous n'avons pas de précision
n'a parlé de thabo m'beki de hugo chavez
mais tout ça ne sont pour le moment que
des rumeurs
l'ensemble des cérémonies elle devrait
se dérouler à peu près sur trois jours
avec un certain nombre d'événements il y
aura des veillées une veillée intime
pour la famille ensuite le cercueil de
aimé césaire devrait parcourir un
certain nombre de quartiers de
fort-de-france et ensuite il devrait
être déposé pour deux veillées
successives dans la nuit de vendredi et
dans la nuit de samedi dans un grand
stade de fort de france la mairie et la
municipalité qui ont organisé cette
cérémonie on souhaitait que le plus
grand nombre de martiniquais puissent y
être associée merci anne un mot encore
sur l'héritage d'aimé césaire depuis
tout à l'heure on évoque notamment cette
idée de négritude qui visait à magnifier
la conscience de l'homme noir a lui
donné la fierté de ses origines
un concept qui a été très discutée qu'en
reste-t-il aujourd'hui daniel wolfromm
thierry breton [ __ ] nous sommes oui et
nous ne sommes [ __ ] le moci péjoratif
et revendiquer en pleine décolonisation
il deviendra négritude autour d'aimé
césaire et de léopold sédar senghor
toute une jeunesse retrouve de chaque
côté de l'océan les valeurs culturelles
de l'afrique noire un message que
césaire portera lui même bien plus tard
jusqu'aux états unis
la négritude faire référence à des
groupes humains qui ont souffert et
souvent souffrent encore d'être
marginalisés et opprimés
mais un siècle plus tard le message de
ces aires at il toujours un sens créé il
ya trois ans le cran fédère une
soixantaine d'associations noir très en
pointe sur les discriminations raciales
nécessaire a réussi à faire en sorte que
jamais on ne puisse évincer les
intellectuels noirs de ce mouvement qui
a vocation à placer les populations
noires au sein de l'universel autrement
dit lenoir à l'égal des autres mais pour
certains ce concept de négritude a fait
son temps si on reste encore sur la
négritude comme fondement d'une unité
[ __ ] ça n'a pas de sens à fait
dangereux ça va crier forcément un
communautarisme totalement bancale
absolument boiteux parce qu'elle ne
repose sur rien sinon sur une
appartenance coloriel la mort d'aimé
césaire que ça représente pour vous la
fin d'une époque une époque commencé
dans les années 30 quand le jeune
césaire découvrait dans le tréfonds de
sa conscience
son identité propre la source de sa
négritude et c'est bien l'écrivain
gaston kelman qu'on entendait à
l'instant et non pas patrick lozès la
voix d'aimé césaire avait porté jusqu'en
afrique ou aux états unis on l'a dit en
france la classe politique salue le
poète des opprimés on écoute nicolas
sarkozy françois hollande et dominique
de villepin
j'imagine le chagrin immense de toute la
population martiniquaise antillaise et
ultramarine qui perd aujourd'hui l'un de
ses pères spirituels mais en vérité en
tant que président de la république je
veux dire que la disparition d'aimé
césaire c'est toute la nation française
qui est andry il a été toute sa vie
durant qui était longue
un combattant contre le colonialisme
d'abord et le racisme
il a voulu que ce combat là en faveur
des peuples opprimés se fasse dans la
république française
et cet homme a à travers son identité
antillaise son identité noire et bien
agrandie l'identité française il nous a
ouvert à d'autres latitudes à d'autres
terres il a retrouvé les racines
africaines de sa propre conscience
voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire ce soir sur
cette disparition
autres titres de l'actualité nicolas
sarkozy a présenté son projet de réforme
de l'hôpital
objectif affiché améliorer la gestion
tout en garantissant la sécurité des
soins
les directeurs d'établissement auront
davantage de pouvoirs il y aura plus de
souplesse dans les contrats mais la
principale disposition vise à regrouper
les services
en clair chaque hôpital devra cesser de
vouloir tout faire
florence bouki à sébastien laffargue
proposition majeure du projet de réforme
de l'hôpital
la création de communautés hospitalières
de territoire
c'est à dire le regroupement
d'établissements publics de santé au
sein d'une même zone géographique les
hôpitaux mettront ainsi en commun leurs
moyens techniques et chacun aura sa
compétence propre au petit hôpital de
campagne par exemple la gériatrie à
l'hôpital central la chirurgie de pointe
d'ici 2012 300 communautés hospitalières
devrait voir le jour
les hôpitaux seront incités à les
intégrer et non forcé mais selon nicolas
sarkozy seul cette réforme peut sauver
l'hôpital public la fermeture des
hôpitaux
c'est si on ne fait pas de réforme de
l'hôpital alors là c'est sûr et je prêt
à faire débat avec qui veut le dessus
désencombrer les urgences l'autre point
majeur de la réforme urgences
hospitalières ou médecins de garde se
partageront un numéro d'appel unique
nombreux sont les usagers qui craignent
la mutation de leur hôpital de proximité
comme ici dans l'essonne une mère de
famille qui n'a eu que 15 kilomètres à
faire pour rejoindre les urgences de
dourdan sa fille a été opéré d'une
péritonite
elle souffrait moko est un donc je suis
contente que l'hôpital soit par an d'ici
un an ou de l'hôpital détente 20
kilomètres plus loin
ce sera peut-être le seul à offrir un
service d'urgence au sein d'une
communauté hospitalière de territoire
et puis les personnels eux aussi seront
appelés à évoluer exemple des
infirmières pourront réaliser des tâches
jusque là réservés aux médecins une
expérience en ce sens et menaient
d'ailleurs depuis deux ans dans
plusieurs établissements
exemple à paris agnès monteux abdeljlil
wesh
préparez des piqûres et des perfusions
c'est bien sûr le travail des
infirmières mais ici c'est aussi donner
des consultations comme le font
habituellement les médecins vous vous
levez juste une fois la nuit
donc c'est tout à fait normal un
questionnaire post opératoire après un
cancer de la prostate
à ce moment je peux vous refaire une
ordonnance qui est même rédaction
d'ordonnancé après un an de formation
cette infirmière devenue assistante
donne un sérieux coup de main aux
médecins je les aide si vous voulez dans
la mesure où je leur avance un certain
nombre de choses et vont le si vous
voulez les patients ont besoin
d'explications
donc je débute un certain nombre
d'explications et va venir vous voir
après vingt minutes de questionnaires le
média finalise la consultation en cinq
minutes d'entretien pouvait vu l'avancé
avec wimm sur une consultation que je
voyais dix patients actuellement quand
chez l'assistante avec moi j'envoie 15
donc que les consulte en augmenter le
volume des consultations et c'est on
sait que dans les années à venir on va
avoir un manque cruel de médecins et si
on ne réorganisent pas les consultations
sur ne réorganisent pas la médecine il
vit on va pas s'en sortir un jour sur
deux claudine plans sombres devient
infirmière cette expérience pilote là
aussi convaincant jours
c'est un moyen développement d'un
nouveau mais si ça se généralise dit
elle il faudra inventer de nouveaux
métiers et mieux les rémunérer comme
cela se fait déjà en grande bretagne ou
aux états unis les suite de la
controverse sur la réforme des
allocations familiales qui aboutit à
diminuer le montant total versé on
l'évoqué tiers
la majoration des prestations
n'interviendra qu'à partir de 14 ans et
non plus 11 ans ségolène royal parle de
volonté de casser les familles le
gouvernement lui a commencé à préciser
les compensations qui concerne la garde
des tout petits
il vient 15 valérie lucas
la compensation annoncée par la
secrétaire d'état à la famille nadine
morano
la voici soixante mille familles
modestes qui font garder leurs jeunes
enfants par des assistantes maternelles
toucheront 50 euros supplémentaires
chaque mois dès le 1er mai une
augmentation de la prestation garde
d'enfants pour des foyers gagnant moins
de 20000 euros par an cette mesure
coûtera chaque année à l'état 36
millions d'euros
une partie seulement des 138 millions
économisés par le gouvernement sur les
allocations familiales restent donc 102
millions ce qui pour l'instant sont sans
affectation officiel ce qui indigne
ségolène royal le gouvernement n'a pas
le droit de voler l'argent des familles
pour faire en plus des économies très
minime
il faut mettre en garde le gouvernement
et lui demander d'arrêter de casser les
familles réponse cet après-midi du
porte-parole de l'ump
madame royal nous fait une fausse colère
elle sait parfaitement que le
gouvernement ne lèvera pas un centime
d'euro sur la politique familiale la
totalité des économies de la réforme
seront mobilisés sur les familles ce
soir la polémique continue associations
familiales et syndicats ne sont pas
convaincus ils s'inquiètent même d'une
possible remise en cause du montant de
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
françois hollande lui accuse le
gouvernement d'imposer je cite un
goutte-à-goutte du supplice avec des
mesures de rigueur annoncées chaque jour
le premier ministre françois fillon lui
a indirectement répondu aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée lors du débat sur la
révision générale des politiques
publiques
il appelle chacun à des efforts à des
remises en cause on les écoute
personne n'a jamais avancé que les
économies ne demanderait pas d'effort
pas de remise en cause
eh bien il est temps d'avoir le courage
de le reconnaître
il faut mener la réforme à bien mais
cela se fera dans la concertation dans
la transparence dans le dialogue
mais je vais vous dire que cela se fera
avec la plus grande détermination
autre réforme en cours précisément
celles de l'assurance chômage qui
prévoit vous le savez un contrôle plus
strict et des sanctions plus directe
pour les demandeurs d'emploi de plus de
six mois
christine lagarde et laurent wauquiez
ont commencé aujourd'hui à recevoir les
syndicats pour
discuter rappelons que le texte précise
qu'une offre considérée comme valable
concernent des emplois située à moins de
deux heures de trajets quotidiens alors
quelles conséquences au jour le jour
voici le portrait croisé de deux
personnes qui ont accepté de travailler
loin de chez elle près de lyon denis
sébastien philippe évêques deux heures
de route aller retour tous les jours
toute l'année
pascal lassaigne habite à 70 km de son
lieu de travail
300 euros par mois en carburant et en
péage
rien que pour aller travailler ce
technicien dépenses 13 % de son salaire
net
je trouve qu'elle est déjà ses entames
pas mal mon salaire quoi donc en dessous
de ce salaire enfin bon on peut encore
descendre un petit peu jusqu'à quelqu'un
qui gagne 2000 euros après en dessous ça
devient tous les matins après avoir
déposé son fils à l'école
ghislaine melet prend elle aussi le
volant 50 minutes de route pour aller à
lyon où elle est secrétaire après six
mois de chômage
elle a retrouvé du travail en intérim
inconvénient c'est à 50 kilomètres de
chez elle
ça fait comprendre qu'une maman sol
puisse puisse leur fusée pallier à tous
les problèmes
paradoxe alors qu'il est question de
rendre la mobilité obligatoire
l'éloignement a été un handicap quand
ghislaine melet à postuler
son employeur craignait qu'elle soit
souvent en retard nettement fait
comprendre que c'était un challenge et
qui fait je n'avais pas le droit de à
l'erreur si j'avais eu un accident le
premier
les premiers jours de mon de ma mission
je savais j'ai été radié ses trajets
l'un comme l'autre ne pourrait pas les
faire en transport en commun
en tous les cas pas en une heure la
mobilité ou l'art du compromis la
nécessité de travailler le salaire à
mettre en balance avec la fatigue et le
coût des transports
toujours à propos d'emploi la
résurrection de certains grands sites de
la sidérurgie française
la forte demande de métaux liée aux pays
émergents et à la relance du nucléaire a
permis par exemple de relancer les
forges du creusot en saône et loire
c'est une bouffée d'oxygène pour la
région est aussi une tradition qui revit
en portage sophie brune vincent barras
c'est un four gigantesque d'où sortent
des pièces d'acier de plus de 100 tonnes
les installations et une culture
industrielle qui valent de l'or
ces pièces serviront à la filière
pétrochimique au nucléaire le site a été
créé au xviiie siècle
aujourd'hui cette forge du creusot est
une des seules au monde à réaliser des
pièces d'une telle dimension
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une phase
où l'industrie notamment dans le domaine
de l'énergie est plutôt très demandeuse
de grosses pièces forgées qui explique
on traverse une phase de pics
historiques en matière de demande à
chalon areva transforme ses pièces en
morceaux de réacteurs c'est devenu le
premier employeur privé du département
après un bac commercial louis libaba
c'est aujourd'hui apprentis soudeur il
se forme dans l'école mise en place par
areva pour s'assurer une main d'oeuvre
qualifiée
plus tard ces armes était très convoité
déjà et à la reva déjà ici à il prévoit
du boulot pour minimum 30 ans car le
marché est en plein essor dopé par le p
r le réacteur de troisième génération
permettent au monde il est plein à trois
temps et les perspectives sont plus
importants comme un croissante qui va
continuer encore vu que le marché
potentiel visé par areva et de l'heure
de dire est de 40 tranche de pnl et dans
le monde en 2025
claude view a lui commencé en 1977 comme
chaudronnier un métier à nouveau très
recherchés il se souvient de son enfance
dans les années 60 à l'époque toute la
ville dépendent et de lusine on avoue t
6 à 4 4 khater donc vous voyez la maison
a bien été réaménagé avant l'avènement
très central et c'était tout des maisons
du personnel ouvrier où il va tous
autour du sinn pas ça c'est clair
mais au début des années 80 lusine ne
résiste pas à la crise de la métallurgie
creusot loire dépose le bilan et toute
la région ces fonds les salariés
manifestent alors devant l'emblème du
creusot aujourd'hui ce marteau pilon
marque toujours l'entrée de la ville
comme un symbole de sa renaissance sous
l'impulsion des pouvoirs publics
plusieurs grandes entreprises se sont
implantées comme la snecma et alstom
c'est florent industriels ont aussi
développé tout un réseau de pn en saône
et loire
l'industrie représente aujourd'hui près
de 50 % des emplois salariés
c'est plus de trois fois la moyenne
nationale la justice en bref le parquet
de versailles a décidé de faire appel
après l'acquittement de lydie debaine
cette mère de 65 ans qui avait tué sa
fille handicapée on en avait parlé ici
même assez longuement pour le procureur
général ce verdict pourrait être pris
pour un encouragement à l'atteinte à la
vie et handicapées et puis les suites de
la sphère de la banderole anti ch'tis la
ministre de l'intérieur michèle alliot
marie a confirmé cet après-midi la
dissolution du club de supporteurs du
psg les boulogne boys à l'étranger pas
de cadeaux entre hillary clinton et
barack obama lors de la reprise des
débats la nuit dernière le camp
démocrate semble plus que jamais divisée
alors que les sondages sont très serrés
avant la nouvelle primaire en
pennsylvanie la candidate a notamment
accusé son adversaire d'être élitiste et
pas assez patriotes alain de chalvron
aaron dimon enfin la 21e débats depuis
le début de la campagne mais le premier
depuis la victoire d'hillary clinton
dans l'ohio et le texas il ya un mois et
demi
entre temps le climat s'est encore
détériorée entre les deux candidats
chacun estime que l'autre devrait avoir
honte de lui-même
le débat s'est pourtant ouvert sur une
amabilité interrogé sur le fait de
savoir si barack obama était éligible
500 euros hillary clinton à articuler un
yes yes yes triple oui sans ambiguïté
reste que la candidate a surtout voulu
exploiter une phrase malheureuse non
filmée d'obama sur je cite l'amertume
des habitants des petites villes qui se
réfugie dans la religion et le culte des
armes
je pense que c'est là une
incompréhension profonde
place de la religion et de la foi dans
notre société réplique du sénateur c'est
le genre de méthode politicienne à
l'ancienne et madame clinton est experte
en la matière quand on leur demande
s'ils pourraient former impliqués
ensemble le silence gêné de l'un et de
l'autre rendiez plus que de longs
discours
ce climat délétère entre les deux
candidats inquiète les dirigeants du
parti et ça n'est pas bon pour hillary
clinton
très en retard en nombre de délégués
elles pourraient subir des pressions de
plus en plus forte pour se retirer de la
course
on reste aux états unis avec les
conséquences inattendues de la crise
financière les cours de l'or valeur
refuge bat des records du coup certaines
vieilles mines fermées depuis la ruée
vers l'or depuis plus d'un siècle sont à
nouveau en activité envoyés spéciaux en
arizona
martine laroche-joubert parce qu'elle
joue frion une ville fantôme dans
l'arizona prospère du temps des
chercheurs d'or à la fin du 19e siècle
ranimé par les touristes
mais aujourd'hui les rêves de cette
époque ressuscite
on raconte que dans ces montagnes
il y a toujours de l'or ça fait des
années et des années que des gens aux
recherches
chaque jour des convois se lance sur la
piste de l'or au pied des montagnes de
la superstition un ancien lieu sacré des
tribus indiennes les a pas nous suivons
un petit groupe lourdement équipés la
chasse aux précieuses pépites ne
s'improvise pas ils ont étudié le
terrain ici le lit d'un cours d'eau
asséchés de vrais spécialistes le
défaire le pari c'est ça arrive quand il
pleut l'or à cause du courant se
déposent au fond du but
le groupe des 125 dollars par an à
l'état pour exploiter cette petite
concession un investissement charger les
soirs il trouve de l'or il n'y a pas d'
or ici j'ai trouvé le terrain
regardez comme c'est joli c'est ce qui
nous motive pour revenir c'est ce jour
là la chasse au trésor est très
fructueuse cinq six sept huit pépites
dans le groupe quelques retraités mais
aussi des hommes plus jeunes soucier
d'arrondir leurs fins de mois
la crise économique frappe durement les
salaires est le fruit de leur mort fait
900 dollars l'once alors vous pouvez
vous faire un peu d'argent avec ça on
voit beaucoup de chômeurs par ici mais
bien des gens avec des petits salaires
apparemment pour eux c'est un bon moyen
d'améliorer leurs revenus
retour dans le magasin d'équipements
miniers de dan le président du club des
chasseurs de trésors passé de 64 cents
en non non c'est l'heure de la pesée du
butin de la matinée
80 dollars en deux heures à peine
les petits orpailleurs vont-ils bientôt
cohabiter avec des groupes miniers
des études sont en cours la fièvre de
l'or reprend dans l'ouest des pionniers
toujours aux états unis en bref benoît
16 a célébré ce matin sa première messe
en plein air au parc stadium de
washington devant 48 mille fidèles le
pape accueilli sous les vivats est
revenu sur le scandale des prêtres
pédophiles
soulignant la souffrance provoqués dans
l'église catholique américaine 1 par ces
abus sexuels sur mineurs le parcours de
la flamme olympique s'est poursuivie
aujourd'hui en asie en inde à new delhi
où quelques seize mille policiers
militaires ont assuré sa sécurité
200 tibétains qui souhaitait organiser
un relais concurrents ont été arrêtés
l'événement en fait n'a duré qu'une
demi-heure dans un centre ville
transformée en camp retranché direction
abou dhabi dans le golfe maintenant on
évoque souvent les difficultés de
l'université française est bien la
sorbonne reste un grand nom qui
s'exporte une filiale de l'université
parisienne a ouvert ses portes là bas la
seconde année universitaire vient de
commencer
l'établissement accueille 200 élèves de
30 nationalités
c'est le dossier de cette édition il est
signé jérôme berman et francis bianconi
c'est une sorte d'université 5 étoiles
ici pas d'amphithéâtre surchargé on
étudie par petits groupes phares à un 18
sur 20 iba 18 sur 20 et pour encadrer
ces étudiants en géographie un maître de
conférences venus spécialement de paris
nous sommes à 8 heures d'avion du
quartier latin
bienvenue à la sorbonne mais version
abou dhabi qui est venu faire la
prestigieuse université ici entre le
désert et le golfe persique
d'abord rivaliser avec les universités
américaines déjà très implanté profiter
ensuite d'étudiants très motivé pour
améliorer la culture générale et une
culture internationale une culture
moderne il faut il faut toujours bouger
il faut être ouverte dans le montre et
puis les émirats ont su se montrer très
convaincants ils financent tout et ne
fixe aucune contrainte à la sorbonne
nous sommes un établissement mixte nous
soleil
nous sommes le seul établissement tous
secteurs confondus a n'a pas avoir deux
salles de prière et enfin nous avons une
bibliothèque qui s'alimentent en
ouvrages sur le marché mondial sans vos
bulles censure ainsi donc les mêmes
profs qu'à paris 10 pensent exactement
les mêmes courants français
exclusivement passe au tableau
on y apprend notre langue en cours
intensifs seule différence avec paris
les frais de scolarité beaucoup plus
cher 13000 euros par an la famille de
chad n'a pas hésité à payer
elle est en première année de droit elle
vient d'arabie saoudite et ses études de
la mode française l'inspirent
j'espère qu'il y ait eu croque tout au
roi de la passe et que c'est mon père
est beaucoup et je voudrais être là
commenté la rama yade ou mais des listes
dodo moyens en 2009 l'université aura
ses locaux définitifs ce luxueux campus
pour deux mille étudiants une
bibliothèque encore plus fourni et au
centre ce dôme réplique des illustres
locaux parisiens désormais sous les
pavés de la sorbonne il y à bien une
plage celle d'abou dhabi l'éducation en
france les lycéens manifestaient
aujourd'hui à nouveau à paris contre les
suppressions de postes ils étaient entre
13 et 50 mille selon les sources un peu
moins nombreux donc qu'avant-hier et sur
la veille des vacances pour l'académie
de paris
quelques incidents ont été constatés en
marge du cortège dégradation ou aux
affrontements
trente sept personnes ont été
interpellées image signée hervé pozzo
xavier darcos ministre de l'éducation
nationale estime vous le savez que plus
de la moitié des suppressions de postes
seront compensés par les heures
supplémentaires proposés aux enseignants
alors les professeurs sont ils
effectivement volontaire
comment ressentir ces incitations
reportage mallory aonuma rica zoo une
issue qu'il juge inacceptable à la
rentrée prochaine cette salle de
professeurs comptera deux enseignants de
moins poste alors qu'on a on a besoin de
18 heures il ya pile le compte on le
supprime
on le remplace par des heures
supplémentaires des heures
supplémentaires à redistribuer entre les
collègues qui reste pas question pour la
grande majorité selon eux la qualité de
l'enseignement est en jeu si on rajoute
même juste trois heures sup c'est une
classe supplémentaire j'en ai déjà 5 à
35 élèves
le calcul est simple je ne pourrais pas
faire un accord un accompagnement
personnalisé on risque d'arriver à terme
à des classes coupé c'est à dire que des
élèves
seconde ou de première et deux heures
avec un professeur de français et deux
heures avec un autre professeur moi ça
m'est arrivé en collège enseignants
certifiés passes 18 heures devant ses
élèves un agrégé 15 heures mais on
estime leur charge de travail à 40
heures par semaine
pourtant ce jeune professeur d'origine
marseillaise s'est résolu à travailler
plus cette année je fais six heures
supplémentaires par mois ce qui me
rapportent 600 euros pendant ça m'est
indispensable pour pouvoir rentrer chez
moi tous les week-ends et a failli ma
famille et tous les mutins
ils sont obligés le recours aux heures
supplémentaires ce n'est pas une volonté
de s'enrichir c'est simplement pour
trouver les moyens de boucler le budget
l'éducation nationale compte sur ce
besoin et pense aussi à son budget en
augmentant les heures supplémentaires de
10 % à la rentrée 2008 elle économisera
5000 postes aujourd'hui un enseignant
n'est pas contraint d'accepter plus
d'une heure supplémentaire les attributs
et peut donc se révéler un casse tête
surtout dans les petites structures pour
les chefs d'établissement on atteint ces
critiques
il faudrait pas ajouter des heures
supplémentaires aux heures
supplémentaires dans les années à venir
parce que là on se rend dans
l'incapacité dé distribuer aux
enseignants le bon déroulement de la
prochaine rentrée sera donc placée sous
le signe des heures sup
selon un sondage paru hier 65% des
enseignantes ne se disent pas prêt à en
accepter davantage politique l'histoire
surprise de la gauche à la tête de la
communauté urbaine de marseille eugène
caselli 61 ans l'emportent face à renaud
muselier pourtant virtuellement
majoritaire renaud muselier qui dénonce
ce soir des traîtres et regrette je cite
encore un déni de démocratie
une idée pour ceux qui ne savent pas
quoi faire de leurs vacances de pâques
on connaissait le tourisme industriel le
tourisme éthique et bien voici le
tourisme scientifique des chercheurs ou
des établissements publics vous prennent
en main et vous guident exemple ce soir
le magnifique site du mont saint michel
et son écosystème françois jullien pieds
noirs prennent eric capron xiiie siècle
d'histoire contemple ce petit point
jeunes en bas de l'image qui connaît la
baie du mont saint michel comme sa poche
de cire et leur chef combler tout à fait
d'accord le petit point jaune est un
scientifique professeur au musée
maritime de dinars et pour lui pas
question d'emmener son groupe de
vacanciers sur le mont beaucoup trop
touristique
non c'est tout ce qu'il ya autour dans
la baie qui
intéresse première étape la chapelle
sainte anne la mer s'est retirée
parfait pour étudier la faune qui s'est
installée et en bon élève certains
préfèrent tout noté formé par endroit ça
peut couvrir ça peut couvrir les fonds
sur des épaisseurs de 45 en asphyxiant
entourant ce qui est de chou ces
touristes sont venus de partout en
france pour trois jours de balade
écologique passage obligé au nord la
pointe du grouin pour des explications
géologique
ici on apprend à lire le paysage ce que
l'on voit fort bien il ya du vert fait
de la végétation peres puis en dessous d
une bande jaune ce sont les lichens john
qu'une bande droit c'est la réponse
effectivement des organismes variations
de niveau de la marée pour 400 euros le
week-end le guide est à la fois
professeur et conteur c'est pas de la
petite histoire quand l'histoire de la
marek iront au galop c'est une légende
par exemple ouais miléi là il a tout ce
fondement scientifique
lui qui peut expliquer la télè revêtent
un tel niveau tel autre à telle autre
écran troisième étape scientifique
cancale bien connu pour ses grosses
huîtres
alors vous voyez les pages de couleurs
qui correspond à bureaux le cnrs est de
plus en plus de musées ouvrent leurs
connaissances aux touristes qui
souhaitent sans dormir plus intelligent
de coucher moins bête c'est exactement
ce que ce que je ressens j'ai pas
l'impression de faire un voyage
militants nico que ça j'ai eu
l'impression de comprendre des choses
sur lesquelles d'habitude je levais pas
le regard ce genre de sortie était
réservé trois généralement il ya 20 30
ans disons à des naturalistes des petits
groupes naturaliste amateur alors que
maintenant on a un public beaucoup plus
là les gens qui se sentent concernés et
sensibilisé par tous les problèmes de
l'environnement pour la dernière étape à
l'est côté normand le scientifique a été
plus indulgent avec ses visiteurs
il leur a accordé un moment purement
touristique celui de prendre quelques
clichés d'un site classé patrimoine de
l'unesco
c'est l'un des plus grands festivals de
musique en france le printemps de
bourges a commencé cette semaine et pour
six jours parmi les têtes d'affiché rose
si son nom ne vous dit rien sa chanson
vous rappellera quelque chose abel
mostefa sylvain aubin
rien à jeter
donné rendez-vous à ses musiciens devant
un café parisien et filières à bourges
par une après midi de printemps garder
en tête qu'il y à peu elle faisait
l'instit et que cette chanson la liste
écrite simplement pour soulager une
rupture à trouver presque par hasard
l'oreille de professionnels de la
musique
je réalise tous les jours la chance que
j'ai on l'a de faire ce virage à 180
malgré moi grâce à des amis à une
chanson à une rupture des peut-être truc
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
je me retrouve à jouer à faire
l'ouverture du festival de manger c'est
ça ces espèces de grandes tentes quechua
quoi comme celle que tu lances le phénix
et ses 5000 places
que de chemin parcouru depuis la sortie
du disque à l'automne 2006 un premier
album proche des 400 mille exemplaires
vendus
et dire que l'an passé à bourges elle
avait joué devant une centaine de
personnes
parce que ça peut être surprenant de
l'extérieur dans le sens de ce qu'on
voit quelqu'un qui démarre et puis d'un
coup on la voit là on la voit encore
plus grand quand on vit le trouve
vraiment il ya tellement de pas et de
d'étapes à franchir que j'ai vraiment
l'absolu et d'avoir d'avoir quand même
passée dans la nouvelle liste de rose
passer aux infos sur france 2 fêter ses
30 ans le mois prochain
jouer à l'olympia et continuer de faire
des envieux
football les amateurs de carquefou 5e
division n'ont pas démérité hier soir
face au psg mais ils se sont finalement
inclinés 1 0 but de pauleta la 77e
minute de jeu l'aventuré s'arrête donc
le tirage au sort des demi finales
avaient lieu tout à l'heure sur le
plateau de notre journal de 13 heures
eh bien ce sera à amiens psg match qui
se déroulera à amiens club de ligue 2 et
sedan lyon match qui se déroulera à lyon
les matches se disputeront les 6 et 7
mai à suivre bien sûr sur france
télévisions avant de refermer ce journal
je vous en rappelle l'un des principaux
titres aimé césaire est mort à 94 ans
poète et homme politique autorité morale
il avait été l'un des fers de l'idée de
négritude la martinique prépare le deuil
l'état va organiser dimanche les
obsèques nationales en présence du
président de la république c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
tout de suite la météo laurent romejko
point route valérie maurice 20h50 envoyé
spécial autour de guilaine chenu et
françoise joly très bonne soirée
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 point fr